من المنطقي تمامًا أن
نأكل الأنواع الغازية
لأن الأنواع الغازية هي مورد لا نهاية
له للطعام هذه القصة الكبيرة
التي أصبحت ممكنة بفضل
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي بون لاي ، أنا الشيف في مطعم ميا
سوشي في ملاذ جديد
منذ 33 عامًا  بدأت والدتي في
إعادة تصور السوشي
كشيء يُجدد البيئة ،
وهذا جزء من النظام الذي يحدث
كل يوم في الصباح
بحثًا عن الطعام
من الأشياء التي
نركز عليها حقًا وهي الأنواع الغازية ،
ماذا لو بدأنا التركيز على المكونات
التي  لا أحد يريد أن يأكل
وفيرًا وحتى مدمرًا للبيئة
، ومن خلال إخراجهم من
البيئة سيساعد في
إعادة التوازن إلى هذا الموطن ، وهو
الخس
البري ، وسنقدم
لهم ثقوبًا في الحشرات مثل الجبن السويسري
وهذا يعني  أنهم يتمتعون بصحة جيدة
لتناول الطعام وأنهم
خالٍ من المبيدات الحشرية ومبيدات الأعشاب
، إليك واحدة كبيرة لا
يمكنك التردد عليها حقًا ، يجب أن تكون ملتزمًا
تمامًا بالقبض عليه
لمعرفة ما إذا كنت  حسنًا ، أنت أقوى كثيرًا
مما
تعتقد أنه يدفع بيدي حقًا ،
نعم ، نحن على استعداد للذهاب ،
دعنا موسيقى الروك أند رول
[موسيقى]
رائعة
هذه القواقع من أوروبا التي يطلق عليها
الحلزون الأوروبي
جاءت عالقة على متن
السفن التي أشعر بها  أنا مثل طفل كبير
يزحف فقط يبحث تحت
الصخور عندما أقوم بجمعها ، دائمًا ما
يكون الأمر مثيرًا بشكل لا يصدق ، إنه أمر مثير للغاية بالنسبة لي ، حسنًا ،
لكن عندما أحاول اكتشاف
طرق جديدة للعمل مع مكون
لم يسبق لي أن  عملت مع
مكون من قبل أو عنصر يثيرني في الواقع ،
أحب حقيقة أنني
أجبر نفسي على مواجهة
تحيزاتي الخاصة اليوم ، ذهبنا للبحث عن
نبات الهندباء قطيفة الخس البري ، mugwort
butterbur ، الجندب ، القواقع الأوروبية الغازية
، مجموعة كاملة من سرطان البحر الآسيوي و
guacama  الأعشاب البحرية و gracilaria seaweed
[موسيقى
] هل ستجنون إذا أظهرنا
للعالم كله أنه يمكنك صنع
السوشي الذواقة فقط باستخدام أشياء في الفناء الخلفي الخاص بك ،
وهذا ما نريد أن يفعله العالم كله
أو يخدعه  sider يفعل أو
يفكر في القيام به وليس فقط أن هذه
ليست فكرة أصلية
كان الناس يفعلون ذلك لعشرات
الآلاف من مئات الآلاف من السنين
قبل ذلك وهو لذيذ ولذيذ
للغاية ومغذي ورائع
للبيئة